كلنا نتذكر اللحظات المصوره لماسات
الزلزال وانهيار المباني لكننا سنتوقف عن
انهيار او عند انهيار مبنى معين في
مالاتيا نيويورك تايمز درست عبر مهندسين
لحظه سقوط مبنى قال مطوروه انه مبني ليكون
امنا من الزلازل الا انه لم يصمت شركه
المقاولات قالت ان تشييد المبنى تم وفقا
لاحدث اللوائح وباستخدام اعلى جوده من
الخرسانه المسلحه بقدمان حديديه الا انها
اعترفت باحتمال حدوث خطا هندسي تسبب في
انهيار الطابق السفلي والمبنى بعد ذلك برج
شيد قبل ثلاث سنوات فقط كما نشاهد في هذه
الصور انهار في الساعات الاولى من الزلزال
وسط سحابه من الغبار بفعل هزه ارتداديه
الصحيفه استعانت بثلاثه مهندسين
انه من المرجح ان سوء التصميم الانشائي
ادى لسقوط المبنى الذي لم تتحمل اساساته
اثر الزلزال واعتبرت نيويورك تايمز ان مثل
هذه الاخفاقات محيره في دوله تحظى بخبره
تقنيه وهندسيه خاصه وان المنطقه معروفه
بالزلازل الا ان القوانين المحليه بحسب
الصحيفه مصدر قلق اخر مع تراخي بروتوكولات
التفتيش بموجب لوائح البناء لعام 2007
والذي لا يتطلب فحص الهياكل بمجرد منح
الترخيص للمبنى مما يعني انه يمكن
للمطورين اجراء تعديلات غير مصرح بها
بدورها نشرت واشنطن بوست تقريرا قارنت فيه
بين التطور في المباني في مناطق الزلازل
وقله عدد الوفيات وضربت مثالا باليابان
وتشيلي وتركيا تشيلي التي شهدت مقتل 28
الف شخص خلال زلزال عام
1939 طورت من قوانينها ومبانيها لمقاومه
الزلازل حتى وصلت حصيله اخر زلزال في هذه
الدوله عام 2019 الى اربعه قتله فقط خلال
الزلازل التي اقتربت شده او هذا الزلزال
من سبع درجات على مقياس رختر حصيله مماثله
اي اربعه قتله كانت في زلزال اليابان
العام الماضي بعدما شهدت في الربع الاول
من القرن الماضي زلزالا مدمرا اودى بحياه
اكثر من 140 الف شخص
ننتقل الى تركيا وبعد زلزال ازمير عام
1999 قررت الحكومه التركيه ان المباني
الجديده يجب ان تكون مقاومه للسلاسل لكن
هذا لم يتم تطبيقه بشكل فعلي على الارض
كما تحدثنا منذ قليل عن قانون العفو عن
الابنيه المخالفه لنشهد الكارثه التي
تجاوزت حصيلتها 32 الف شخص حسب التقديرات
الاوليه